[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise you i am gonna get her back
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i could use your expertise
you comment or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise to a dinosaur yeah
what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
see not so bad
[Music]
[Music]
these hands were once used for battle
now they've got humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
[Music]
exactly who i am
[Music]
i want to choose my own path
live in the moment
[Music]
my superheroing days are over
[Music]
remember what i told you
you ever feel lost just look into the
eyes of the people that you love
[Music]
not me
what just listening
[Music]
[Music]
what's the first thing that pops into
your head when i say chip and dale i bet
it's these guys but certainly the second
would be those rascally cartoon
chipmunks chip and dale
what if i did something like i am into
good good i love it
[Music]
just want to remind you guys i'll be at
fancon this afternoon hey watch out
i'm keeping myself fit and you know my
updated modern look don't you think
you'd have more fans here if chip did
these events with you i haven't thought
about him in a while i should give him a
call see how life's treating him life is
the worst
which is why you need good insurance
a message on my landline
i don't like that
i know you're still mad about rescue
rangers getting canceled but i just got
a call from the police and i need your
help
i searched the perimeter no clues why
would there be six missing tunes in a
month and not one clue
oh no
chip gail you look
different it's no secret i had the cgi
surgery what's been up with you you know
this that other vague things to fill the
space of this conversation cool
we can see what we can find out and then
pass it along to the officer that that's
all we're gonna do so you're saying the
rescue rangers are back yes
you two come poking around where you
don't belong and i can't have that
i gotta go
what are you looking at honestly your
weird dead eyes
over here go get em
this is awesome
[Music]
i was always more of an alvin in the
chipmunks person you
monster
it was like professional
same time
you owe me a non-brand specific cola
what that was crazy somebody's called
his book
this is incredible
would you like to see a magic trick yeah
[Music]
tell me your name
taylor
i was really starting to like you
finney
i almost let you go
[Music]
it doesn't work
hang it up
i made you some breakfast where'd you
put that
salt and pepper
[Music]
have you seen this boy
my brother he was taken i mean with
black balloons
i had a dream about it
please let the dreams be real
you're getting out of here oh
there's a combination what's the
combination
you're gonna use a weapon
[Music]
creepiest damn thing
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking no no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
i'd like lightyear to star command come
in star command
why don't they answer
hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long have we gone yum yum yum
yum 62 years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was gonna be like a
fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
you know what's saying the harpoons
[Music]
right here
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2
seems a bit low
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a better oh no please record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vomit inside the vehicle if you are
satisfied with this recording speak or
select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
[Music]
guys i get so stressed out every time we
play this someone always ends up crying
[Laughter]
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the x on it you are the murderer
[Music]
our friend is dead so if you could just
like not escalate this situation that
i'm not escalating you're holding the
knife and you're moving your hands while
you talk
that would be so [ __ ] obvious if i
were the killer david moore
you're always gaslighting me
you [ __ ] trigger me you are so toxic
relax relax you're silencing me
did you just [ __ ] shoot me i can't
believe you're making this about you
[Music]
what are the features that you're
bringing well i just look like i [ __ ]
you know what i mean
i look like i [ __ ]
and that's the vibe i like to put out
there yeah
this is harris what would i do without
you this is harris it's the solar
discretion one would never know she'd
been but for the polish on my knobs
that's what we are by the invisible
women kiss me once and kiss me twice
then kiss me
[Music]
your head is never coming
back for the moment dreaming
that's where you are
you're a dreamer
you should have been receiving a war
widow's pension becomes quite a tidy sum
who is my attic it's a sign from my
angel what are you going to do i'm going
to buy a dress a christian dior from
paris
paris
i'm after a frog one of
please let me squash you out no no no
hang on a minute i saved every penny
scrubbing floor so i can buy this drop
excuse me but it would be my honor to
have you view the collection as my guest
how will you do that this is harris you
are nobody invisible
mother may i give you a lift what was i
thinking come in here i'm just a cleaner
from london no your cleaner dreams are
the most beautiful gal in the world
it's not sewing it's faking moonlight
you dare to follow your dreams mrs
harris well this is not possible not at
all where you're going with this harris
to see the boss
this is house these are for you from mr
lamaki
i've spent too long on my own wishing my
life away you'd only do the same thing
this is your chance
i have never encountered anyone like you
come on girls follow me today there's a
new woman a modern woman
i thought it was too late
now i'm not so sure
who's that like looks the monster
himself mr dior he looks like my milkman
i noticed the moment you walked in the
door
you have that extra something special
you're a real star
[Music]
i'm tired of playing to mid-sized crowds
in nashville we can do something bigger
[Music]
cheers still early y'all going to raise
some hell or what let me grab my purse
oh my god or for dutch lee and i are
obsessed with the duchess sisters
is that her house uh yeah
what if i told you i got harper dutch's
address how did you get that caleb gave
it to me
oh i bet he did
[Music]
we can't just show up at our house
[Music]
so you want me to do a song with you
y'all any good well we'd love to show
you which one of you is better oh we're
equals yeah you better drink my damn
booze
torn hearts with harper dutch is a great
idea we're doing a solid hard work
this is how we celebrate
[Music]
this is weird pretty sure harper killed
hope
oh my god
harper's trying to turn us against each
other
this is my house i will tear it to
shreds to get to you too
the girls just came by for some free
advice on a whim nothing's free in
nashville is it
[Music]
where am i i have no idea i just woke up
in this field
now here we are okay
come on out
this doesn't make any sense
how did we get here
what did you find
matches
i got this
she's got a knife and my compass
we need water
the food
you think we found something by now
come with us we'll find a way out
there is no way
whatever that thing is it's coming for
us next brian can you look at the bottle
it's a tree so what i think there's more
to these items than just their obvious
functions
i think it's a map our hearts are
messing
up this line's up
if you don't need me
this is a game to them
i'm done
[Music]
why do you want to be a samurai
[Music]
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times and maybe could use some help
himself
but where can i find one
get out of here who even made that
it's you don't believe everything you
read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
[Music]
make
hey this is the training montage isn't
it sometimes you need a friend
[Applause]
nope
don't forget to land on your
feet
[Music]
send a tweet to assemble the troops
who knew an evil army could go through
so many beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the mother father cocker spaniels
going on here
the legend of hank
time to finish this
this might take a while
[Music]
stupid [ __ ] nowhere every year i made
it didn't i
this week is sacred
we're going to fire island and this is
why straight people hate us
and also heteronormativity
judeo-christian pathology
anal
for whatever reason call it magic time
sort of works differently here
[Applause]
and that is our makeshift little family
we all met 10 years ago working at the
same cursed brunch spot bottomless
mimosas [ __ ]
jackie chan hey you got a refill here
bud
i can't believe you talked me into this
again i come here i just feel terminally
alone
oh are you all right it's fine it
happens all the time do you want some
whiskey it would help with your knees
and trust me i'm a doctor
do they have a house on the beach but we
can't go over there we are literal trap
nice excuse me i think you may have the
wrong house
have you seen the way they're drinking
they're clearly using us for free liquor
well promise me you'll try to have a
good time do not let these people think
that they are better than us because at
the end
never mind
okay guys like that are ruining this
island play harsh time
i have never met somebody who's made it
so clear that they think they're so
superior than everybody else i don't
think i'm better than you
[Music]
you think that if you're vulnerable for
just one second that it's all going to
come crashing down oh my god my baby's
drowning i don't think i want to be
implicated in this dj
oh you guys you're like all i have we're
family that means something to me we're
gonna like hug and wrap this up how does
this end why don't we just get a little
cup and dance
the defense is wrong my biological [ __ ]
is thicker like this penelope cruz oh
[Music]
who's looking in your file
you're not the usual fish are you
i see that sort of behavior
as an advantage for you
it could be advantageous to everyone
including your country
want a gig
tell me more
we kidnap people
and transport them to other countries
willing to look the other way while we
interrogate them
what do you want do you know this guy
he's radicalizing young kids you got a
20 on the target
you know what's required get your hands
dirty
no restraints
target's secure
the clock is ticking
somebody is really aching for this guy
there's something they're not telling us
i'm just a foot soldier they don't tell
me anything
the more we know the more we're
accountable to
our mission is to keep the wars small
and sacrifice is meaningful
just because you're american
doesn't mean your colleagues share the
same goal as you
we have a problem
why are we descending there's been a
major shift i'm pulling the plug
that guy knew we were coming it's
definitely a trap
for all we know this guy's controlling
the whole goddamn thing
what next we get ready
all i know is control in order
for some bigger picture we're not seeing
no matter how messy this gets
i'm not your enemy
we play a complicated game allegiances
change
we're officially in cleanup mode
it's time for plan b
so what's plan b
kill em all
extraction 10 seconds
let's do it
wait anyway
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up daniela
[Music]
[Music]
it is time to stop seeing
[Music]
it is time to stop speaking
[Music]
it is time to listen
it is time to stop seeing
it is time to start speaking
it is time
to listen
listen
listen
[Music]
once upon a pair of sneakers there lived
a boy who was full of creativity you
believe that sneakers are a window to
the soul
if you put enough of yourself into a
design it's gonna hit
once i slip on that sneaker
it's my story
but possibility and opportunity can feel
as far away as a castle in the clouds
seeker royalty designed for the king
brand that's my dream
we need to dominate speaker khan we need
something big we need a new voice
someone fresh find a designer that
speaks to you tells a story we'll try it
out
now we just gotta find him
you are very talented i just scribble in
my notebook i'm a stock boy i think i
hear your stepfather talking this is the
real world not some doodle or some
nonsense you're dreaming about
and clean that up too
he held tight to his dreams but would
this kingdom give him a chance boom the
king's charity gala yeah design some
safe kicks there's not enough time for
that
come on you've got sneakers to make
kicks
kicks
you put in the workout you're ready for
the big night then
[Music]
sorry
wait a second did you design this you're
the guy that everybody's been talking
about
i really gotta get them out of here wait
a curfew thing
what would become of his dreams
well that would be its own kind of magic
[Music]
[Music]
you